in this video i'm going to tell you the
number one way to increase the
percentage of sales that get closed by
you and your team through a systematic
process and if you don't know who i am
my name is alex romizzy i own
acquisition.com it's a portfolio of
service
coaching e-learning info businesses that
do about 85 million a year and i have
nothing to sell you and so the reason i
want to make this is years ago i was
recruited to bring in or to be brought
in and flown in for a
sales consulting gig which i don't do
and it was years ago but the team was
selling mortgage leads and so they
wanted me to do is the first half of the
day i i took apart the the actual sales
script and rescript everything kind of
reframe the offer all that kind of stuff
and the second half of the day i was
supposed to uh train the team and so
after spending the first half on that
talking to the founders all that kind of
stuff the second half they had a nine
person team and they were selling
mortgage leads and when i walked in the
first thing that i asked the team was
hey and they were like hey this guy
john's been kind of a problem i was like
okay cool i was like hey john how good
are the leads whole team's there it's
quiet ever like pressure's on john
he's like well i mean they're uh and i
was like i'm good thanks so much and
everyone was like what is happening i
was like dude i can give you the best
script in the world i was like but if
you don't believe in the product i was
like none of this is gonna matter i said
if you believed in the leads i was like
you wouldn't even need the script
because if you were to ask me the same
question and i truly believe that these
leads were amazing i would be like dude
these leads are sick i mean right now my
my cousin is a realtor and i'm sending
her leads right now because she's
already building so much of a pipeline
from it i'm actually studying for a
realtor exam so that i can so i can buy
these leads from this company and not
even sell these but sell houses instead
right because houses have a bit bigger
ticket than these leads do and so for me
like i'm just basically waiting to get
through to that point so that i can move
out on my own but yeah i mean these
leads are awesome so the way that you
talk
about the products that you have will
indicate the level of conviction that
you have and the best sales people are
true believers and you that's why a lot
of great salesmen come from clients
who've used the products and services if
it makes sense for them you know for for
their life and whatnot and so people
will believe like if you think about
what sales really is it's a transference
of conviction and so you've got some
person who doesn't believe one person
who does believe and trust is what
completes the transfer and you have to
duplicate the conviction in this person
and this person and so if a salesperson
doesn't believe in the product they have
no way to transfer the conviction
because they have no baseline of
conviction to work off and a different
version of this happens when people
start hot they do really well and all of
a sudden they start not selling as well
it's not because they don't know how to
sell and training is not the thing
that's going to fix the problem because
they're already closing before and
they're not closing now it means they've
changed something and oftentimes it's
because they've heard something from one
of the prospects that they sold that
something was not good and so the way to
prevent this and to actively increase
conviction which is what's going to
change the way they say the words on the
script is by actively having a process
to make them believe and so obviously
the way to make a believe is to actually
have a good product but in terms of
systematizing that it's having a regular
cadence between customer success and
sales so this is me getting a little bit
operational with you but this is how it
works you meet weekly and you have both
teams on and the people from customer
success share the wins of the clients
who are going through the program that's
on a weekly basis it's a long form
format it also serves as as a way for
them to talk back and forth to each
other the sales team can see what's
happening on the customer success sites
customer system i can see what's
happening on the sales side and you
create
cross-departmental knowledge which is
really useful because the sales team
knows not to say some things because
people are misunderstanding them and the
success team is giving the sales team
ammunition for the things that they know
that they're doing to deliver that makes
them more convicted on top of that you
should have a pipeline that is
established for customers where you can
collect testimonials and reviews and
what you do is in the best case scenario
you have that client hop on with the
sales team and explain their story and i
can tell you this because me firsthand
one of the things that i realized when i
looked at our stats was that on
saturdays and particular saturdays we
were closing like 100 percent of people
were walking in the door and i was like
huh what's different about these days at
my facilities versus the days that we're
not you know we're closing a normal
amount and it turned out that those days
were the days that we would actually do
the way outs for our program so people
would finish their six week or their 12
weeks or whatever it was and we would do
all the way outs on the same day and so
it's kind of like a graduation ceremony
so everyone steps on they're crying
they're losing weight they feel amazing
but all of my team was there and so when
we had sales consults that were that
morning or throughout the graduation day
or right after the graduation well it's
all fresh in their mind they would when
someone walk in it's like the sales took
half as long because the belief and the
conviction was so strong in the salesman
it overcame the fears and the doubts of
the prospect right and so in a lot of
ways you have to compensate for
lack of conviction with training and you
know learning logical based frameworks
and and learning how to have excellent
conversation right that help people make
decisions but if you truly believe and
if you think about how we buy things as
prospects we buy these things because
somebody recommends them and we believe
the person like think about an organic
buying process right someone says hey
have you gone to that sandwich shop it's
awesome like you're like well great i'm
gonna go there right like why would i
not and so the closer you can have the
trust so that when you make the
recommendation it's like having a
referral the person will believe you
because the way you are saying it is
believable and the way to make it
believable is to actually believe it and
so having a structured process of
increasing the conviction of the sales
team is a way to massively increase the
closing percentages of your team not
based on skill but based on heart and so
if you can bridge that gap between the
customer success and the sales team and
you can do that both internally and
externally internally because you have
processes externally because you get
those customers on the call so they can
hear the stories but also you and the
sales directors can read those
testimonials every single day to them in
the morning and i like that because it
sets the cadence for the day because it
reminds us why we do what we do on a
regular basis
why am i taking these calls why am i
knocking on these doors why am i setting
up shop and and collecting leads at the
whole food so that i can so we can make
sales later like why am i doing this i'm
doing this so that i can be a part of
this transformation these people are
going through as a result of whatever
products and services we sell and so the
sales team probably more like customer
support and sales i feel like are very
similar in that they get beat up all day
long and sales people especially so this
is for the founders and the ceos are
going out there and they're fighting for
you every single day they're the front
line in my opinion they're the offensive
line of the team they're just pushing
they're in the in the trenches moving
the ball forward every you know one two
yards at a time they're chipping away at
it let's see if i can get this camera
back and they're pushing your products
forward every single day on your behalf
and so the biggest thing that a sales
director and if you're the sales
director because your business is
smaller is that you have to breathe
conviction into them because their
conviction can wane over time and it's a
cup that has to be refilled because it's
that conviction that they're spreading
to all the prospects and the thing is
the prospects are spreading doubt into
them and so you have to fill it up from
your side so that they can become
diluted and then get refilled right
which is why a good sales person comes
in they can crush and all of a sudden
they start going down it's not because
of skill because they already had the
skills they already knew how to they
already knew how to close when they came
in the problem was their mojo was off
mojo
mojo
mojo and so this video is fundamentally
about fixing mojo within a sales team
which is just getting them to believe
and reminding them to believe which is
why one of the biggest sayings i have in
sales is we need to be reminded more
than we need to be taught people who
believe in something automatically sell
it and i'll give you a final final
example to drive this point home i'll
just use the the christian community
overall or really just any kind of
religious community in general a big
part of most faiths is spreading the
faith and you can tell
when someone truly believes the faith
they're on fire with the face because
they they truly believe it and it's not
like people go through sales training
right to bring people to faith they just
truly believe in it and if you've ever
been around someone who has absolute
conviction because conviction and this
is a key point is not do you believe in
the product do you not believe in the
product but to what extent do you
believe in the product how much and how
deeply do you believe
that is the predictor of your ability to
close a massive predictor of your
ability to close which is why so many
founders are always some of the best
promoters for their businesses because
they believe in it more than everyone
else and they should be but you can
duplicate that ability in getting other
people to believe by having a process in
place to do so and understanding that
the training the blocking tackling in
terms of like say this and that and say
this and that sure it's important it's
good to have those they're tools right
they're tools that you have in your tool
belt but the fundamental work ethic that
someone will fight and their desire to
actually help someone is the difference
between them thinking about themselves
so they can get their commission check
and then thinking about the prospect and
how this person is missing out on
something that's genuinely going to help
them and really transform their life and
really solve the problems that they have
and they will fight for the sale so much
longer because they genuinely want this
person to win because they genuinely
believe that your products and services
are actually going to help them and so
bridging that gap and understanding this
for myself was so important because a
lot of times we get obsessed with the
drills and all that stuff and you have
to do that stuff for sure you have to
drill you have to understand how to say
the words all that kind of stuff but the
heart if you can if you could change the
heart and you can depth in right because
it's not just like i said it's not just
do they believe but how deeply convicted
can i get this team to be and that is
where having proof where you're actively
selling your sales team that is where
you will get the outsized returns in my
opinion on increasing the effectiveness
of the team is that they truly and
deeply to their core belief and the last
point that i was making is if you've
ever been around someone who truly
believes in something and it's like kind
of insane like whatever the thing is
like it could be aliens it could be
whatever right like something crazy but
they are like so sold on it there is an
element of yourself that wonders if
you're right because you have conviction
too in whatever you believe and so you
see their depth of conviction their
depth of faith in the thing that they
have concluded and the deeper it is the
more you start to question your own
beliefs which is why the pastors of huge
churches typically have deep deep faith
and if like there's a lot to study in
terms of converting people literally
because you're changing someone's entire
world view and so if you study the
process that people come to faith and
how they convince others to come to
faiths in general there's a lot of
elements of selling that occur there in
helping people make decisions to help
themselves and so the person who
typically does the converting can never
believe less in the thing that they're
trying to convert someone into than the
person who's being converted the person
has to believe in your conviction more
than they believe in their doubt in the
story that they have been telling
themselves and so
the skills are simply a way to clearly
communicate and build trust so that your
conviction can be transferred but it
starts with having the conviction to
begin with in order to initiate the
transfer over the bridge of trust and so
this is the number one thing that i see
missing from sales trainings and it's
one of the easiest things that we can do
to implement in a team or even in
yourself to improve your numbers overall
in your business all right and if you
don't know why i am i probably said it
earlier but if i didn't my name's
auctionmoji we own acquisition.com
portfolio of services info coaching
course businesses that do about 85
million a year and i have nothing to
sell you all right and so i make these
videos because i struggled a lot coming
up and i just if i if there's any
lessons that i can share i would prefer
that my pain not have been in vain
alright so lots of love and i'll see you
guys next video bye